let's do a quick review of contango and
backwardation because they really are
opposites of each other but they're used
in different contexts sometimes with the
exact right meetings sometimes with the
not so right meeting so let's clarify
what we're talking about so if you hear
a commodities traders say that a market
is in contango they're normally just
referring to the fact that you have an
upward sloping futures curve so what
would technically be just you call it a
normal futures curve because it's upward
sloping they would call it contango it
sounds a little fancier and if you were
to hear commodities traders today that a
market is in backwardation they're
really just talking about an inverted
futures curve they're just talking about
something like this now if we were to be
more precise with those that's how it's
used in kind of common everyday lingo
but if you wanted to be more precise if
someone were to talk tell you that we're
to talk about contango theory contango
theory maybe in an academic setting then
they're talking about the notion that
the future delivery price is actually
higher than what people expect the price
to be at that date the problem with that
is it's just a theory and there's no way
to know ahead of time what that expected
price actually was so it's very
theoretical
similarly if someone is talking about
backwardation theory or even I guess
more particularly if they use the word
normal backwardation if they say the
theory of normal backwardation they just
don't say backwardation by itself they
say the theory of normal backwardation
they're talking about the idea that the
future delivery price is lower than some
expected price because these the seller
is willing to sell the discount so that
they can essentially lock their prices
in but once again it's a very
theoretical idea it's really hard to
observe it in the real world because you
actually don't know what the expected
price is so someone is saying
backwardation they're usually just
talking about it inverted and inverted
futures curve if someone talks about
normal backwardation or the theory of
normal backwardation they're talking
about the idea that the future price the
future delivery price is below the
markets expected price I've even seen
the word normal can
Kengo used when they're talking about
contango theory the idea that the future
price would be above the expected price
so contango theory is the opposite of
the theory of normal backwardation now
for both of the theories you never know
what this expected price is so you can't
literally observe it a snapshot in real
time and the closest thing we can do to
observing either a real contango in a
market or real normal backwardation in a
market is if in the example of contango
if the future delivery price right now
is higher than the expected as we get
closer and closer to that delivery date
it should converge or it should move
down so you can kind of observe contango
over time when this price moves down as
we go forward in time this is a snapshot
this is it moving in down moving down as
we move ahead in time
same thing for normal backwardation the
only way that you can really observe it
or even attempt to observe it is to look
at what happens to this price over time
in eight months the delivery price is 50
dollars but as we move future as we move
forward in time and that contract
becomes closer and closer to its actual
delivery date it will converge with the
spot price and it will move up so this
observation of the few of the futures
price moving up as you get closer to
delivery some that's a better way of
observing that a market is experiencing
normal backwardation hopefully that
clarifies some things